foreign
[Music]
Ty and I'm a YouTube influencer I
suppose a woodworker artist I'm going to
walk you through how I restore a rotting
Christmas sleigh I was involved in a TV
series here in the UK which I got given
the sleigh to restore it was brought in
from Lithuania so the sleigh was pretty
old I'm not too sure exactly how old it
was but it could be 100 years I would
have no idea but it was definitely
pretty old first of all it's covered in
this green like a lime green paint that
somebody's painted I'm not sure if that
was the original color or not it's got
Twisted bars in it the metals all
twisted and battered half the seats
missing on it so there's there's
certainly a lot of work to do
first what I've got to do is unbolt all
of the sleigh the best thing to try and
with this type of restoration is to try
and unbolt everything I can using
different tools because there has been
some different types of nuts and bolts
added to this over the period so I'm
trying different spanners and ratchets
and sockets and things just to try and
get everything unbothered that I can
now I'm going to wire brush the entire
sleigh as well because I just want to
get off all the rust I can uh so it's
probably been on here for years and
years so why brush and everything as
much as possible
so there's like bits of the patterns on
the side there some bits that are
missing in there so I'm going to need to
kind of recreate and reconstruct those
there's an old bit of wood that I can
lose from this to use to cut out the
pieces I'm going to have to chop out a
few of the bits and pieces that I need
from that Old bit of sleigh wood
I'm going to use a jigsaw to cut out the
shapes or the missing parts and then try
and sand it back and glue it in
what I'm gonna have to do to try and
re-create the pattern that's missing on
the other side is just check out the
side that is whole and sort of Trace
that side and then flip it over and then
try and cut out a similar shape to fit
into the missing pattern
now I'm going to have to make a seat for
this sleigh because there isn't one
that's disappeared
so I'm gonna biscuit join the pieces of
wood together to try and make the seat a
whole piece
so when you put the biscuits in I'm
gonna have to put some glue in and get
it all clamped up and leave that
overnight
[Music]
so now with the seat that's now ready
and all glued up I'm gonna have to try
and rough this up a little bit so I'm
going to burn it just try and make it
look a bit old and sort of like in
keeping with the sleigh really because
it's a new piece of wood we've had to
make this seat completely from scratch
so really you're gonna have to burn it
up bang it with a hammer a few times you
know like it's been there for a hundred
years
foreign
the entire sleigh down as much sanding
as possible there's going to be a lot of
hand sanding involved and I'm gonna have
to use a few machines like all the tool
Sanders just to really try and get as
much of this green that someone's
covered this slaying and also with the
metal work as well because it is very
Rusty and it's got some really old paint
on it gonna try and get all that back to
Bare Metal just to try to get off all
the old stuff and preparation really for
the new paint
I want to paint the frame black there's
obviously a few different ways to paint
sleighs but I want a sort of traditional
Santa sleigh and from what I know what
I've grown up to no obvious that the
Santa sleigh is kind of like a bit red
obviously and it's got some black in it
so I'm gonna go with the frame
completely black and then start paying
all the wood A nice bright vibrant Santa
sleigh red
this sleigh is going to need a few coats
of this red because it's going to seep
into the wood quite a bit so we're gonna
need a few coats of the red on it the
black's gonna cover quite well so that's
going to come up alright and I think
with this piece it's going to need hand
painting really because there's so many
individual little areas and little bits
that meet up to the black metal I think
it's just going to be easier to just
hand paint it it's going to take a lot
longer but I think the Finish is going
to be much much better
now I'm gonna have to use a tiny
paintbrush just because it's just a bit
more of a detailed section I want to
make sure I don't get the paint all over
the other paint that I've just put on
there
so I've managed to keep all of the
aluminum that's been put around this
sleigh I'm gonna have to put it all back
in now just basically using some new
Nails just hammering there was really
just making sure it's all banged into
place and it is that type of sort of
aluminum you can just bang it and mold
it around you know the wood and stuff so
it makes it look quite cool anyway
now I'm going to fit everything together
so I'm going to put the new seat in that
I've made get that bolted in and secure
with the backrest on there there's a few
new bolts so I can't have to add into
this because some of them couldn't
really get off before
so that is the sleigh finished the end
story to this is absolutely pretty
amazing because it was part of the show
I obviously had to sell this sleigh and
it's actually was purchased by a chap
who runs a shop in New Zealand so if you
wanted to see this sleigh or actually
take a seat in the sleigh it is now sat
in New Zealand in a shop called the
Christmas Hut
foreign